what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so getting into the Justice League of
America one shot for Caitlyn Frost what
I want to do here is I want to wind back
for a second and I want to jump back to
what amounts to her secret origin
basically for those of you guys who
don't know DC has a line of comics
called secret origin they haven't really
done it for DC rebirth and I don't think
they will they did it for the new 52 but
it basically runs over the origin
stories of the various characters most
of them focus on superheroes but when it
came to super villains a lot of this was
covered in forever evil now we'll get to
that here in a second but for the
character of Caitlin Frost we don't need
to go super in-depth here with her
origin largely because of the fact that
we're focusing on the the Justice League
of America rebirth one-shot but this
will give us a better understanding of
what her character was about so in terms
of Caitlin's smell again you know she's
basically a new creation for DC you know
prior to her acquired a new 52 you had a
couple of different iterations of killer
frost she was always kind of a mainstay
but the caitlin snow character was kind
of this villain turned antihero turned
good guy this natural progression of a
character over the course of its
publication history and it worked out
pretty well for her but the way things
functioned is that Caitlin snow was just
like this extremely intelligent
scientist with regards to STAR Labs
course STAR Labs being or an advanced
research group that focuses on a myriad
of different things you know how to
understand superpowers but in this
instance this STAR Labs research group
in an in the Arctic is focusing on how
to harness perpetual energy basically
creating a situation where there'll be
infinite energy for everyone forever and
so you know Holmes won't have to rely on
traditional forms of heating and cooling
you know you'll have cars that won't
rely on gasoline no rely on perpetual
energy different things like that the
issue here and what we find out is that
where Caitlin snow is able to fix this
machine and get it working like it's
supposed to
this group is actually bought out by
hive now hive is like this weird
organization that's basically just kind
of obsessed with the return of Brainiac
you know the idea that they're kind of
prepping the world for brainiacs return
they kind of view themselves as heralds
of his of his arrival on earth but hive
had also sustained itself by investing
in a myriad of different forms of
finance and and you know different
different aspects of the economy one of
which was energy and so the idea is that
if this machine ever actually came to
market everyone's ever actually
developed and put into the public sector
it would lead to a complete and total
collapse of the energy system as it
exists for you know wealthy corporate
companies instead they would all go
bankrupt because nobody would have a
need for oil nobody would have a need
for electricity nobody would need those
things you would have some perfect
energy source that would power
everything that exists on earth no it
would take a time you know take time for
it to roll out but it would basically
spell the doom of the traditional energy
sector and so with hive buying out these
STAR Labs guys the goal was that
basically just always create the
illusion that no one could ever get the
machine to work the way it was supposed
to but with Caitlin snow successfully
pulling it off the idea was to basically
kill her break the Machine down and then
just communal repeat the process of
bringing people in for the purpose of
trying to get the machine to work
keeping the illusion that they're trying
to keep the skilling under STAR Labs but
always you know hiding under the current
that they're basically working for hive
and so the idea was that with the
character of Caitlin snow once these
researchers figured out what was going
on that she got the machine working like
she was supposed to they basically threw
her inside of it with the purpose of
activating it and killing her in the
process but it basically granted her the
ability to manipulate you know the cold
now of course this is a result of her
own actions and panicking yanking out
the coolant coolant systems and
literally just being you know having
ourselves bonded with this perfect
energy and cooling itself allow her here
to go forward as somebody who could
manipulate elemental forces but the idea
remains that following the emergence of
killer frost she basically fell into a
very primal instinct in the sense that
all she wanted to do is feed because she
has to feed on the life energy or the
body heat or whatever or what-have-you
of people in order to sustain herself
and so she literally killed all the
researchers and then just took off to
Pittsburgh now this was DC wrapping back
around and saying here's her origin
story when she first appeared and the
firestorm comics in the new 52 when she
was going against firestorm it's just
kind of the way these things progressed
with her character and it was cool to
see it happen but this eventually led
directly into forever evil now again
forever evil was the story that was part
of this this multifaceted lead-up to
Darkseid war when it was the crime
syndicate of America from Earth 3 the
evil Justice League basically invading
the planet Earth for the purpose of
escaping their realities destruction at
the hands of the anti-monitor and so the
result was that it led to the defeat of
the Justice League the Justice League of
America as it was formed then and we'll
talk about that here in a second and
then it basically led to lex luthor
creating his own superhero team and that
of course led into what we're seeing
with lex luthor right now in DC rebirth
where he's basically a good guy but the
idea here is that Caitlin Snell again
went from being a villain to an antihero
to a good guy and with regards to
Justice League of America rebirth this
is Caitlin snow basically becoming a
hero now the other thing I want to talk
about here is the entire notion of the
Justice League of America as it exists
so when the Justice League first popped
up in DC Comics back in 1960 it was just
called the Justice League of America
that's really what it was and it ran for
about 27 years until crisis on Infinite
Earths when they cancelled it and they
replaced it with Justice League
International now in terms of Justice
League of America as you know it in the
new 52 as you remember it that's based
off Justice League International what do
you see it done is they had looked at
Justice League International was a team
led by Batman it was wildly popular just
because of the fact that it was filled
with people whose comics wouldn't
normally sell on their own and the
result was that we got some weird
combinations of characters we would
normally never see paired up together it
was cool there was a lot of bickering a
lot of infighting you know a lot of
realistic portrayals of how these
personalities mix and mash when they're
thrown into unfamiliar situations but by
the time 1998 came around fans were
hankering for a return of the
traditional Justice League and so what
we got was Justice League of America by
Grant Morrison JLA that was the regular
Justice League now discontinued on until
the new 52 and here's what DC did when
the new 52 launched because it was
designed to be a line wide reboot the
traditional Justice League of America
roster Batman Wonder Woman the one
though the roster that you think of was
wiped away and the title was simply
called Justice League at that point we
got Justice League International for the
new 52 and it was a new 52 reimagining
of the team that we saw post crisis with
Batman and Guy Gardner and all those
guys but eventually that title was
canceled and it was turned over it was
rolled over into the publication Justice
League of America and that's why we had
those two titles running at the same
time you had Justice League which was
the main DC creme de la creme
superheroes and then you had Justice
League of America which was everybody
else that he you know the small-time
guys but they fought their own villains
they had their own schemes they had
their own structures he had Justice
League dark which was like the whole
supernatural side Constantine all those
folks but it was a cool line of comics
because it gave us a lot of stories with
characters that we wouldn't normally see
now of course eventually Justice League
of America was cancelled and it was just
Justice League itself and that's really
all he had what rebirth does is it gives
us back Justice League of America but
what it does is it basically takes the
premise of JLA as it was formed by
Batman post crisis on Infinite Earths
and it rolls it over into DC rebirth
while serving the same function that the
team served during new 52 so it's a
really cool combination of these two
aspects and that's why rebirth is kind
of a mishmash of what worked between the
new 52 and the pre new 52 continuities
and DC Comics I hope I haven't lost you
there but if I have things get a whole
lot simpler now so when it comes to the
character of killer frost again after
Justice League versus Suicide Squad
it was DC sitting down and saying she's
trying to be a good guy I mean she was
shanghaied into the Suicide Squad for
Rhonda she had committed the idea was
that this part of Suicide Squad if she
had carried out her missions effectively
time would be cut off of her of her
prison sentence but during the entire
event Batman had come to realize that
killer frost was basically a good guy
especially when she essentially saved
the life of everybody at the end of the
story and so because of that Batman once
who went to Amanda Waller and said hey
look your suicide squad has some good
folks in it they can be used for better
purposes than going out on suicidal
missions for any number of reasons and
so the goal of Batman was to allow
killer frost to basically serve her
sentence to a degree but intervene have
paperwork filed that would have her
removed from the suicide squad team and
thrown on to the Justice League of
America team as it was reformed by
Batman the funny thing about this is
that again this is really Steve Orlando
showing us Amanda Waller in her most
basic in the Simpson Amanda Waller is
controlling she's manipulative in her
mind she's like you know look killer
frost like I I know you're a killer like
you're a murderer you're a criminal it's
only a matter of time before you prove
me right and she's like if I let you out
of here you're gonna go on and you're
going to be a bad guy and it's gonna
result in the deaths of maybe some
heroes certainly some civilians and then
suddenly everything that you've worked
for is gonna come crashing down now keep
in mind this is not Amanda Waller being
altruistic all right this is not Amanda
Waller doing the right thing for the
sake of it being the right thing no no
this is Amanda Waller being controlling
this is her trying to manipulate trying
to goad killer frost into believing that
she's still a bad guy the cool thing is
that it doesn't work but the other half
of this is Amanda Waller says hey look
you know even if you are a good guy well
shucks killer frost the paperwork to get
you out of here just got lost in the
shuffle so they're gonna have to refile
and it's gonna take a few days at
minimum so you know I don't I don't know
if you're gonna be able to make it in
here and of course the whole base is
behind what she means without you know
kind of a passive aggressive threat is
that what Amanda Waller starts doing is
throwing these various situations at
killer frost in an effort to get her to
act out to you know basically act vile
so that you know amanda waller can go
forward and say see i told you guys she
was a criminal I told you guys she was a
bad guy
she has to stay as part of the Suicide
Squad now keep in mind one reason why
she's doing this is because killer frost
is very powerful we saw that during
Justice League versus Suicide Squad the
power she possesses is proportional to
the amount of body heat of life energy
that she absorbs that was confirmed
during the whole event of Justice League
versus Suicide Squad if it hadn't been
confirmed before you know if she was
absorbing various humans she had you
know her normal powers she absorbs some
of the solar energy off of Superman and
suddenly was insane the amount of energy
that she possessed even she looked
around and said wow I've never done
anything like that before and so the
amount of power that she's able to use
at any one time is directly proportional
to how much life energy how much body
heat she absorbs from the individuals
around her the kicker about this is that
again you know a lot of the people that
she encounters are really one of the
most notable comes in the form of heat
stroke now of course heat stroke being
here is just kind of like the antithesis
of killer frost as a character whose
body relies on heat in order to survive
so that it could maintain its cooling
form being exposed to perpetual heat is
like a huge weakness for killer frost
and so it's Amanda Waller trying to wear
her down is Amanda Waller trying to get
her to succumb to the fact that unless
heatstroke is forced out of this room
unless her powers are taken away
killer frost is basically going to die
so it's kind of creating this
desperation situation it's kind of
creating this this issue where it's like
you know killer frost could either
absorb the life energy and the heat of a
heat stroke herself and kill her in the
process in order to keep herself alive
or she can just kind of deal with the
situation and that's what that's what
you know killer frost does she just
copes with the situation the issue here
is that we also have enemies of
heatstroke that make their way into the
end of the cell and then suddenly start
accosting her you know start to start
tormenting her beating her up that kind
of thing and killer frost the initial
idea is a man who was like hey look the
only option killer frost is gonna have
is that if she's a good guy she's gonna
have to take these guys out but if she
is a good guy and she does take these
guys out then yet again I can point to
the idea that she's a bad guy because no
one's gonna know the truth of the
situation except for Amanda Waller
people are going to believe her my so if
Amanda Waller comes out and says hey
guys look what killer frost did see
she's a bad guy well it destroys any
credibility the killer frost has and so
because of this you know Caitlyn just
kind of grins and bears it for a time
but eventually she just sort of lashes
out and pins these guys up against a
wall and so instead of killing them
instead of absorbing their energy
resulting in their deaths instead she
just holds them in
and so it's basically the idea that both
heat stroke and killer frost could say
hey look here's what was going on here's
why they're pinned to the wall they
shouldn't have even been in here in the
first place well then she hasn't done
anything wrong
you know she's basically pointed to the
idea that you know Amanda Waller put us
here now of course we're the manda wall
our being the warden holding the keys
you know being the one running the show
well who's anybody gonna tell I mean
they're not gonna go over Amanda
Waller's head because to do that would
be to incur the wrath of Waller and
that'd be a foolish thing to do and so
because of this Waller says look it's
only a matter of time like you're
getting outta here we're pulling the
bomb out of your head you're gonna be
fine but it's only a matter of time
before you become a bad guy the tests
never end I'll be watching you
constantly and the first mistake you
make the first slip-up the first
innocent that gets hurt under your watch
the first time that you deviate away
that you absorb somebody's energy the
first time any of this happens I'm gonna
be there to catch you I'm gonna be there
to find you I'm gonna be there to be the
one that's going to end up stripping you
of your freedom and bringing you back to
the suicide squad not only that we
actually find out that what killer Frost
has been doing it's keeping your powers
in check and this is actually genius
when Batman says is your hunger under
control she says yes what she's been
doing is walking around and touching
various people and drawing out miniscule
forms of heat instead of drawing out a
whole bunch of energy from a singular
person she's going around and drawing
heat from five or six or seven different
people at a time and it's a genius way
to do things because she constantly
keeps her energy up but nobody's injured
in a process what seems like an
accidental bump or what seems like an
edge of the finger is her drawing off a
little bit of energy from that person in
order to keep her self sustained it's a
genius way for her to function and is
really Steve Orlando saying hey look
here's how far her characters come as it
just being primal instead of just
running up on folks and grabbing him
absorbing their energy and I'm killer
force you know she's just like absorbing
heat from a coffee cup where she's
touching the finger of each stroke you
know she's hitting somebody's shoulder
she's tripping them but she's making
physical contact and siphoning off just
enough energy to basically keep her
stores up but again you know because of
this I'm actually really excited to see
what's gonna happen with with the whole
you know Justice League of America
rebirth again just like all the Justice
League of America teams that we've seen
following crush on different others it's
just a mishmash of people that we would
never see paired up on a single team and
so it makes some really really
interesting relationships um interesting
of situations for the people involved
but if you guys are new here to come as
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the rod for if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]